comm check we're live I pushed hard in
the earliest meetings I had where Tom
Cruise JJ Abrams and I went to parama to
discuss what we wanted to do with this
movie and I pitched the idea of shooting
several sequences in IMAX for me the
most immersive experiences actually the
filming the nightmares because the
detail and the clarity is just
unparalleled we have about 25 minutes of
the film that is that way maybe slightly
less than the Dark Knight which is the
last film that really shot extensively
in IMAX Red Death you were just showing
people snippets of the film and people
are getting vertigo because the screens
are so big that they actually feel like
they're gonna tumble into them
and that's the kind of stuff you live
for as a filmmaker because it's an
experiential medium so the more you can
make it like a dream and like reality
but you know a dreamlike version of
reality that's what you're going for you
you want to sweep people away and take
them somewhere you're not gonna make it
you're not helping
I love showmanship and I wanted all the
first people that saw this movie to see
it at its best so we are opening in IMAX
on December 16th five days before it
opens why that way all the first people
that see this film will see it at its
very best so I just wanted to like bring
it break out the showmanship you know
what I mean what happens now your
mission should you choose to accept it